Yeah, I would say just as a small aside,
that's why reading as I'm almost done with, uh,
the rise and fall of the third Reich. Oh yeah. Is, uh,
it's, uh, refreshes the resets,
the palette of your understanding of what is good and evil in the world that I
think is really useful now. Like, you know,
what helps me be really positive and almost naive on Twitter,
uh, and in the world is by just studying history and,
and, uh, comparing it to how amazing things are, uh, today.
But in that time, what
would you do?
What does the brave mind do and
not just, uh, acts of bravery,
but how do you be effective in that?
And that's something I often think about. It's sometimes easy to be an activist,
uh, in terms of just saying stuff it's hard to be effective at your
activism. One of the big questions historians have, uh,
constantly is how did this happen? A to make sure it doesn't happen again,
but this is Germany. This is not some kind of weirdo cult nation.
They're very advanced, very in Atlanta, poets and philosophers.
How did it get to that point that they're just shooting children and everyone's
cheering for this,
and specifically on the anti-Semitism and the Holocaust [inaudible] and the
cult of Hitler. And it was just this whole kind of thing.
The size is starting to drop, but there's two sides.
I don't know if you want to separate them. One is the totalitarianism and the,
the entire, the entirety of the Nazi regime. And then there's the Holocaust,
which is like, you know, going,
I would say like very specifically,
uh, as I think you're about to describe as like, you know,
targeting Jews very much.
So I don't know if you see those as two separate things.
I think they're very interconnected, but I think if you look at it,
everyone thinks that they'd be the ones putting up Anne Frank.
But if you look at the numbers,
they'd be the ones calling the Staci on her or whoever the people were at the
time and not the Staci, obviously, uh,
and patting themselves on the back for it. So, sorry to pause on that.
It's a really important thing. If you're listening to this,
that you were not, you were in Germany at the time,
you would have likely been willing to commit,
or at least keep a blind eye to the violence against Jews.
Like you have to really sit with that idea that you would have been
somebody who, uh, just sees this and is not bothered by it.
And also very likely kind of understand this as a necessary
evil or even a necessary. Good. Yeah.
And I people think that they would be,
the abolitionists are marching on Selma the numbers. Don't add that,
add up to that at all. And I think the question will be like, what social I,
my friend was on Tinder, my friend, Matt. Who's a great dude.
And the question was, what's the most controversial opinion you have.
This is New York. And the girl wrote, I hate Trump.
And what people perceive themselves as being courageous in saying, and doing,
and what is the actual social costs of you saying,
or doing this are two very disconnected things.
And we're also trained by corporate media to have completely
vapid, uninteresting, banal ideas.
And yet regardless cells as revolutionaries, you know,
there are people who still in New York will take pride because they have a gay
friend. And it's like, first of all, who cares?
But second of all, you are not a hero and that person's not your prop,
by the way. That's another big problem.